Hallo, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Kapagann. Ich bin hier als Dienstabendarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anwesende gespürt führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Bevor wir über Ihre Aktuelle Bescheidung sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell eine Frage an meine Frage an sich stellen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Herr Doktor, guten Abend. Sie sprechen sehr schnell. Ich habe Sie kaum verstanden.
Okay, mein Name ist Kapagann.
Kapagann, sehr schön. Was ist das für ein Name? Was bedeutet das?
Eigentlich bedeutet das eine Altename in türkischer Geschichte.
Ja, eine Altename und das sagt, haben wir diese von meinen großen Eltern angenommen.
Hat es eine Bedeutung?
Eigentlich keine Bedeutung, nur eine Name von König. Alten König in türkischer Geschichte.
Das ist aber schön. Das folgt auch. Sehr gut. Guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Ja, guten Abend. Danke. Kapagann kann sagen die Leute, die Experten Kapagann kann oder Kapkan kann auch können sagen.
Sehr gut. Dann sage ich mal, Doktor, Kapagann zu Ihnen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden, bevor wir über die Altename sprechen.
Ich möchte Sie ganz schnell eine Frage an sich stellen. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Matthias Schönreich.
Matthias Schönreich, können Sie Ihre Vorname und Nachname bestabieren?
Vorname ist Matthias, Martha, Anton, Theodor, Theodor, Henri, Ida, Anton Siequitt, Matthias.
Genau. Doktor und Haar. Genau. Doktor und Haar. Ja.
Und Schönreich. Schön und reich. Genau, schön reich.
Herr Schönreich, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt. Genau.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren, wann genau? 23.08.1979, glaube ich, 79.
Genau, ja. Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Oh, Sie wollen aber Sachen wissen. Ich wiege circa 75 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schönreich?
Ich glaube, 1,72 Meter, muss das sein.
Genau, danke schön. Und was für welche haben Sie?
Was für Sie zu uns, Herr Schönreich?
Herr Doktor, meine Frau schickt mich heute hierher.
Sie sagt, dass meine Haut und meine Augen ein bisschen gelb geworden sind.
Mir ist es nicht so aufgefallen, aber ich dachte, ich war in den letzten Tagen unter der Sonne.
Es war ja sehr warm in den letzten Tagen, dass das vielleicht durch die Sonne kommt,
aber meine Frau meint, nein, ich soll mich zeigen.
Okay, genau. Seit wann sind Sie gelb geworden?
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt, meine Frau hat es wohl gestern schon bemerkt.
Okay.
Heute ist es anscheinend etwas mehr.
Mhm, ja. Und haben Sie irgendein Schmerz?
Schmerzen habe ich an sich nicht.
Okay. Und Ihre Haut, wo genau Sie in Ihrem Hautbereich,
die gelb geworden sind? Wo genau sind diese Bereiche?
Also Sie können mich hier anschauen, Herr Doktor.
Also meine Frau sagt, meine ganze Körper ist etwas gelb, meine Augen.
Augen auch.
Ich habe es bemerkt, sie sind ein bisschen gelb geworden, aber meine Haut,
ich kann es schlecht einschätzen, aber meine Frau meint, die ganze Haut ist gelb.
Genau, okay. Leiden Sie unter Yuklis?
Nein.
Haben Sie etwas Speziale essen gegessen?
Nein, ich esse ganz normal wie immer.
Sind Sie gegen etwas oder sind Sie gebissen, gegen Zicken?
Also ob ich von einer Zecke gebissen worden bin?
Genau, oder haben Sie eine Zecke gebissen gehabt?
Nein, Zicken bis habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht gehabt.
Genau, okay. Und Sie haben auch keine Schmerzen irgendwo.
Nur Ihre Frau sagte, dass Ihre Haut und Augen gelb geworden sind,
seit gestern und heute ist ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Und Yuklis auch, haben Sie keine?
Genau.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, natürlich, ich habe überhaupt keine Beschwerden, mir geht es gut.
Ich finde mich gar nicht so schlecht.
Okay.
Hast du einen Ausfall oder eine grühe Nage oder andere Beschwerden?
Also ich habe mich jetzt nicht aufgefallen,
ich sehe nicht so viele Haare, habe ich jetzt nicht,
aber das ist schon länger schon so.
Okay.
Aber sonst habe ich an den Händen bis mir nichts zu tun.
Außer diese Gelb geworden, Gelbverfärbung, andere Hautrötung
oder Hautausschlag, leiden Sie darunter?
Leiden Sie darunter, Hautausschlag oder andere?
Ausgleich habe ich nicht, aber ich merke,
dass ich seit ein paar Monaten immer wieder so blaue Flecken habe,
wenn ich mich irgendwo anstoße oder am Bein oder am Fuß,
so kleine blaue Flecken, die gehen wieder weg,
aber ich habe nicht dabei gedacht.
Genau, ja.
Am Fuß oder am Knie, in den Augen?
Genau.
Okay.
Und füllen Sie sich müde?
Auf der Baustelle.
Bitte?
Ich arbeite auf der Baustelle.
Ich maure und Handwerker.
Das heißt, ich muss natürlich manchmal schwere Sachen heben
oder mit verschiedensten Werkzeugen arbeiten.
Genau, ja.
Füllen Sie sich müde als sonst?
Nein, an sich nicht.
Ich finde mich eigentlich wie immer.
Habt ihr Sie keine Fieber?
Ja, das wussten Sie?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Herzstorben oder Herzlasen?
Also bisher hatte ich keine Herzprobleme.
Leiden Sie unter Luftnord oder...
Nein, ich hatte keine Prüfe gehabt.
Okay, Ende der für den Brustkorb auch?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, aber an sich nicht.
Okay, Sie haben nicht erbrochen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich kann jetzt nichts schlimmer sagen.
Mein Appetit denke ich, ist normal.
Ich esse ganz normal.
Und da habe ich aber bisher keine Probleme.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungehört auch dazu genommen?
Also mein Bauch ist ein bisschen größer geworden.
Okay.
Ich habe mir jetzt erst mal nichts dabei gedacht,
aber das geht auch schon seit so einem halben Jahr, glaube ich.
Wo ich dachte, ich habe einfach nur viel Luft im Bauch.
Der Bauch ist ein bisschen größer geworden.
Genau.
Seit sechs Monaten, ja?
Ja, aber das hat ganz leicht angefangen.
Das ist mir jetzt aufgefallen,
dass in den letzten drei, vier Wochen,
da habe ich das Gefühl, dass mein Bauch ein bisschen dicker geworden ist.
Dicker geworden, genau, ja.
Ich habe mich auf die Waage gestellt.
Ich habe jetzt wahrscheinlich so 1,5 Kilo zugenommen, aber...
Ich esse nicht viel.
Genau. Sie haben nicht viel gegessen.
Aber nicht mehr als sonst.
Ich esse eigentlich immer so wie bisher.
Genau. Sie haben 1 Kilo zugenommen, ja?
Ja, fast 2 Kilo.
2 Kilo.
Wie viele Monate, letzte Monate?
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich jetzt noch dreite angewogen.
Ich habe jetzt noch 3 Tage angewogen.
3 Tage.
75 Kilo.
Und ich hatte mal eigentlich 72 Kilo.
Oder 73 Kilo.
Genau.
Aber ihr habt Bettins und ist normal.
Ist nichts mehr.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich würde es als normal bezeichnen, ja.
Genau, ja.
Ich esse sowieso nicht sehr viel, ja.
Genau.
Da haben Sie Bauchschmerzen in der Rätseite,
oder nach dem Bettins-Gesessen.
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen unangenehm,
wenn der Bauch so ein bisschen groß ist.
Aber ich habe da keine Beschwerden.
Okay. Leider Sie unter Belegungen?
Manchmal.
Manchmal, genau, ja.
Leider Sie unter Durchfall oder Verstuchung?
Nein, der Stuckung ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Im Gegenteil, ich mache mal eher sogar leicht den Breigenstuhlgang.
Breigenstuhlgang, genau.
Aber ist normal, ja.
Ja, ja.
Tierschuhl haben Sie nicht bemerkt, ja?
Was ist ein Terstuhl, Herr Doktor?
Terstuhl ist ein Dunkelblut,
oder ein schwarzes Blut im Stuhl,
wenn wir bemerkt haben.
Genau.
Nein, das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen,
dass der Stuhlgang schwarz war.
Das habe ich noch nie gehabt, ne?
Genau, okay.
Stuhlgang.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen beim Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Auch keine?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, klappt auch ganz gut.
Nein.
Urinstatus, wie ist die Urinstatus?
Ist normale Urinfarbe oder ist dunkel geworden?
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt, Herr Doktor.
Das spüle immer gleich.
Okay, genau.
Müssen Sie Sauer aufstoßen?
Achso, nee, Ansicht nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Sortbrennen?
Nein, ab und zu mal, aber ich möchte aufgehen.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Abgeschlagenheit,
oder so, wenn Sie sich anstrengen?
Zum Beispiel...
Ja, das merke ich.
Dass ich schneller müde werde, oder?
Das ist mir die Kraft zum Fehl, der Stund.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Schoenreich,
ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte etwas fragen.
Leiden Sie an eine wichtige chronische Erkrankung?
Konntet ihr das wissen solltest du?
Ich bin blubska Krankheit oder Bluthochdruck, oder so?
Ich habe bisher eigentlich keine Erkrankungen gehabt, war immer gesund.
Ich muss sagen, ich war auch sehr selten beim Arzt,
weil ich eigentlich fast nie krank war.
Okay.
Hatten Sie früher erniescher Beschwänzen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und deswegen sind Sie nicht beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ja, genau.
An die Krankheit sozusagen.
Ja.
Und keine Vorerkrankungen, Sie haben gesagt,
und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Oder bei Bedarf?
Nur wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen oder so habe,
aber regelmäßig...
Ja, welche Medikamente wegen Kopfschmerzen nehmen Sie ein?
Das sind Medikamente, die man so aus der Apotheke kaufen kann.
Dann brauchen wir keine Rezepte.
Paracetamol oder...
Ja, genau.
Paracetamol.
Genau.
Wie viel Medikament?
Keine Ahnung, Herr Dr.
Ja, okay.
Ich nehme mal eine oder zwei Tabletten und dann geht es wieder.
Okay.
Und sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Oh, wie meinten Sie?
Also gegen Polen habe ich ein paar Legeen, aber ansonsten
ein sich nicht.
Okay.
Und sind Ihnen Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Unverträglichkeiten, vom Nahen zu den...
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, lauchen Sie, Herr Schönreich?
Ja, leider ja.
Nein, dann seit wann lauchen Sie?
Oh Gott.
Seitdem 16 bin.
16 bin, genau.
Das heißt seit...
Das heißt seit 27 Jahren...
Also schon seit...
Genau, ja.
Wie viel Päckchen am Tag lauchen Sie?
Ja, ich meine, auf die Saarweite, auf dem Bau, wenn da immer viel los ist.
Also ich mich ungefähr eine Schachtel pro Tag lauchte.
Eine Schachtel pro Tag, okay.
Ja.
Nehmens, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Bitte?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, schon.
Ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, und welcher Alkohol?
Trinken Sie Wein oder Schnaps oder Bier?
Also harte Sachen trinke ich nicht.
Also ich trinke eigentlich nur Bier.
Bier?
Über den Tag ein bisschen, wenn...
Aber und abends mal manchmal ein Wein, aber viel ist es nicht.
Genau, gelegentlich trinken Sie.
Ja, so schon täglich muss ich sagen.
Genau.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine medizinische Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Droge nehmen?
Drogen?
Ja.
Nein, habe ich früher mal als junger Mann mal probiert.
Das ist auch ein Haarstil, mal andere Sachen, aber das mache ich nicht mehr.
Keiner.
Zwei, wenn Sie Sport?
Oh, ich würde dich gerne machen, aber dazu habe ich echt keine Zeit.
Ich schaue gerne Fußball, aber ich habe keine Zeit.
Ich schaue gerne Fußball im Fernsehen, das ist mein bester Sport.
Ja, im Fernsehen, wenn wir es machen.
Ja, und Deutschland, Fußballmarschwald natürlich ist sehr schön.
Das ist nicht die Gemeinschaft, das stimmt.
Ja, genau.
Und keine Sportmomenten.
Sie schreiben keine Sport.
Ja, ich habe keine Sport.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Oh, da habe ich keine.
Ich weiß, dass ich immer Tetanus hatte, aber sonst habe ich glaube ich nichts.
Okay.
Tetanus, Sie haben Erhante natürlich wegen dieser Baustelle.
Ja, wegen der Arbeit müssen wir das nicht tun.
Da wird es immer kontrolliert, aber ich glaube, ja, der Arbeit ist...
Okay.
Mediziner, ich bin da.
Hab ich es, ich pass dabei oder können wir gucken?
Nein, leider nicht.
Gegen Corona-Infungen?
Das muss man machen, weil da bin ich schon dreimal geimpft.
Okay, genau.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Also, wir waren letztes Jahr mal in Afrika für zwei Wochen, aber war alles in Ordnung.
Letztes Jahr, ja?
Mhm.
Okay.
In Wercherland waren Sie?
In Kenia waren wir.
Kenia, okay.
Aber alles ist gut und andere...
Die Impfungen haben Sie eraltet, die vor der Reise müssen wir Impfung haben,
normalerweise vor dieser Reise.
Welche Impfungen meinen Sie?
Ja, die zum Beispiel gegen Malaria, können wir sagen, oder...
Die lassen wir später sprechen, ja.
Also, ich weiß, wir haben uns natürlich beraten lassen.
Genau.
Da haben wir gegen Malaria Tabletten bekommen, da hieß es, es gibt keine Impfung,
aber Tabletten.
Okay, okay, genau.
Und andere Impfungen speziell, da haben wir jetzt nicht gebraucht, nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Herr Schornreich, ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Familiengeschichte,
der Familienerkrankungen etwas fragen und Familienanwesen auch etwas fragen.
Sind Sie verheiratet oder wie ist die Familienstatus?
Ja, ich hatte meine vorhattliche Geschichte, ich bin verheiratet.
Genau, ja, Sie haben gesagt, genau.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, auch nicht.
Meine Frau möchte unbedingt eine Handlaber.
Ja, genau, ja.
Und mit Ihrer Frau, jetzt wohnen Sie zusammen?
Ja, ja, genau.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich hatte mal ein Bruder, aber mit dem rede ich nicht.
Ah, okay.
Wissen Sie, dass Ihr Bruder auch etwas Erkrankungen habe?
Nein, so weit, ich weiß, ich hatte keine Erkrankungen.
Okay, genau.
Und lebt Ihnen Ihr Eltern noch?
Nein, alle nicht mehr.
Meine Mutter ist vor fünf Jahren verstorben, mein Vater letztes Jahr.
Okay.
Woran ist Ihr Mutter gestorben?
Sie hatte Buschgebs gehabt.
Und mein Vater hat einen Schlag an dem Fall bekommen.
Ihr Vater letztes Jahr ist gestorben, ja?
Ja.
Ja, da muss ich sagen, als du seitdem mein Vater gestorben ist,
muss ich gestehen, der trinke ich auch immer etwas mehr Alkohol.
Okay, genau, ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Ich trinke da gerne auch mal etwas anderes noch,
ein bisschen Wein und ein paar andere Sachen.
Genau, ich verstehe Sie.
Nein, ich bin eine gute Beziehung zu meinem Vater,
aber das hat mich schon sehr getroffen.
Meine Frau schimpft auch immer mit mir,
dass ich abends vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel trinke,
aber das tut mir gut, ja, von daher.
Genau, ja.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Wenn Sie etwas, eine Hilfe brauchen
oder eine professionelle Hilfe für diese Situation,
eine emotionelle Situation brauchen,
können wir gerne Ihnen helfen.
Ja, gleich soll ich noch mal.
So eine Gesprächstherapie machen.
Genau, ja.
Vielen Dank für das Angebot, muss ich mir überlegen, ja.
Ich möchte Sie, Mutter und Ihr Vater,
an wichtige Erkrankungen erlitten.
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Roskrebs und Apokalyse.
Genau, okay.
Und Sie arbeiten in einer Baustelle,
Sie arbeiten als Handwerk
in einer Baustelle.
Genau, in Maurer.
Genau.
Und sind Sie damit zufrieden?
Ja, ich liebe meine Arbeit, ja.
Das ist gut.
Können Sie, oder ich muss jetzt
eine Kurzzeit-Besommepassung für Sie machen,
ich möchte machen.
Und dann, wenn Sie etwas hinzufügen möchten,
können Sie gerne hinzufügen.
Herr Matthias, schön reich.
Sie haben seit gestern
eine Hautverfärbung gelbäck geworden
und Augen, ihre Augen auch gelb geworden.
Sie gelb geworden und deswegen sind Sie bei uns.
Und Ihre Frau hat sie zu uns geschickt.
Und ein paar Monate haben Sie auch blaue Fläche
in Ihren Ellenbogen und Gelenken
und auch am Knie und Beinen.
Und Sie haben auch bemerkt,
dass Ihr Bauch dicker geworden ist in der letzten Zeit.
Und Sie leiden unter
Abgeschlagenheit mit Blühungen
oder anderen,
ein bisschen 2 Kilogramm Zunahme
wegen dieser dicker Bauch.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Ihr Beine angeschworen sind?
Ganz leicht, ja.
Leicht ein bisschen angeschworen.
Und Kopfschmerzen,
andere Bauchschmerzen oder andere Schmerzen,
irgendwo wurden Sie fernangeht.
Oder haben Sie fernangeht?
Und möchten Sie jetzt etwas hinstufen?
Nein, vielen Dank.
Sie haben sich sehr viel Zeit genommen, Herr Doktor.
Wir gewinnen das Problem.
Und meine Frau kann wieder beruhigt sein.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass ich bald wieder nach Hause bin.
Ja, genau.
Ich möchte jetzt Sie erklären,
dass Sie sich hier bei uns bleiben müssen
für weitere Untersuchungen und Behandlungen.
Jetzt kann ich Ihnen leider nicht etwas sagen,
was zu tun ist.
Aber erst möchten wir, möchte ich eine köperliche Untersuchung machen
und Belut aufnehmen von Ihnen.
Und ein paar Untersuchungen,
weitere Schritte durchführen,
zum Beispiel Bauchutrauschall oder andere auch.
Dann werde ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich zu Ihnen kommen
und sage Ihnen, was zu tun ist.
Sie nehmen auch Blut ab, oder?
Genau, natürlich.
Verstellerte Blutwerte werde ich anschauen.
Besonders Leberwerte und andere Insündungswerte
werde ich anschauen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Sehr gut.
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen?
Oder Kolleginnen?
Ich habe keine Frage.
Guten Appetit.
Was ist der?
Mein Gast.
Was gibt es zum Abendessen?
Der Teller ist aber schon wieder leer.
Er ist ein Türkischer Reis.
Ich habe keine Peterve gefaltet.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Petra.
Der ambitiative, motivierte Arzt,
Dr. Mehmet, Servus.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Danke schön.
Sie sind wieder gut drauf.
Haben Sie einen Patienten?
Ja, habe ich einen Patienten aufgenommen.
Dann schießt mal los.
Herr Matthias Schönreich ist 43 Jahre alt.
75 kg schwer.
1,72 m groß.
Herr Matthias Schönreich ist ein 43-jähriger Patient.
Der ist 75 kg schwer.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Sie sind ein Triod booster Ur preferred.
Das war einer der das Ichsteris von der
Internationalen
hat. Ich, Terus, bin langsam aufgetreten, seit gestern. Und heute ist es schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient habe bemerkt, dass die blauen Fläke seit ein paar Monaten in ihrem Ellenbogen und Beinenbereich.
Was sind das für blaue Fläcke? Haben Sie das angeguckt?
Ja, ich habe auch angeguckt und die Erritema können wir auch sagen.
Oder ist es Hematom?
Hematom, genau.
Okay.
Und außerhalb hat der Patient mitgeteilt, dass er eine Bau- oder ihr Bau dicker geworden sei seit sechs Monaten.
Der Bauumfang ist größer geworden.
Der Bauumfang ist größer geworden seit sechs Monaten.
Und der zweiten Leid der Patient, der Klarteter Patient, über ein Metorismus und Vertüge und leichte Beinödämme.
Und Sie haben mit dem Ultraschall angeschaut, hat er eine Ascetis?
Ich werde bei körperlicher Untersuchung eine Autobau- oder Optomenzoneografie durchführen.
Und bei dieser Untersuchung werde ich Ascetis auch anschauen und beurteilen.
Der Patient hat Ascetis und zwar ausreichend?
Genau, der Bau ist dicker Bau, das ist Ascetis.
Der Bau ist nicht gleich Ascetis, aber dieser Patient, ich gebe jetzt die Information.
Dieser Patient hat im Sono einen ausgiebigen Ascetis.
Ascetis, genau.
Im Sono haben wir Ascetis bemerkt und beurteilt.
Die Weggartite an der Messe sei unaufgängig bis auf eine zwei Kilogramm Gewichtsunahme in den letzten drei Tagen.
Und ein Metorismus, wie ich gesagt habe.
Ansonsten...
Entschuldigung, jetzt muss ich noch unterbrechen.
Zwei Kilogramm in zwei Tagen?
Drei Tagen eigentlich.
Gewichtsunahme.
Gewichtsunahme, der hat gesagt, oder?
Im halben Jahr.
Halben Jahr, okay.
Zwei Kilogramm Gewichtsunahme und Metorismus.
Leider.
Und es gibt keine relevanten oder keine wichtige Vorherkrankungen bei diesen Patienten.
Der Patient nehme bei Bedarf parasitämol ein.
Und es gibt keine OP bei diesen Patienten.
Keine Voroperation.
Genau, keine Voroperation.
Und die Frage nach Englisch beschwerden wurden vermeint.
Und die Frage nach Schmerzen in anderen Körperteile wurden vermeint.
Der Patient sei allergisch gegen Polen.
Und der Patient braucht seit 27 Jahren ein Schäktel Protakt.
Das heißt 27 Paktioniers.
Also er hat einen Nikotin-Abusus.
Genau, Nikotin-Abusus seit 27 Jahren.
Und der Patient trinkt Alkohol, Bier und Wein.
Und abends trinken Bier und Wein.
Seit ihr Fahrtage gestorben seid.
Genau, trinken ein bisschen mehr.
Okay, und wie viel haben Sie gefragt?
Wie viel Alkohol er jetzt trinkt?
Wie viel Wein trinkt er?
Einfach Bier.
Trinkt er am Tag, oder?
Haben Sie genau nachgefragt, wie viel Flaschen er?
Ja, ich habe gefragt, aber ich habe zugehört, gelegentlich, glaube ich.
Was bedeutet gelegentlich?
Die Patienten sagen nicht immer die Wahrheit.
Da müssen Sie immer etwas nachhaken und schon genau fragen.
Sie haben doch gesagt, der arbeitet auf dem Bau, oder?
Ja.
Der ist ein Maurer.
Da ist es so, dass auf dem Bau sehr viel Alkohol getrunken wird.
Meistens kommen die Leute morgens schon mit einem Kasten Bier auf der Baustelle.
Bis zum Abend ist alles ausgetrunken.
Deswegen sind das ja harte Jungs, die vertragen einiges.
Deswegen sieht man, dass ihnen nicht so oft an, dass sie Alkohol trinken.
Am Abend trinken sie meistens auch noch ein bisschen was.
Deswegen müssen Sie bei solchen Patienten immer genauer Menge Erfragen.
Wie viel Flaschen Wein morgens, mittags, abends oder Bier,
oder noch andere Sachen, damit sie ungefähr die Alkoholmenge pro Tag berechnen können.
Genau, ja.
Ich werde diese beiden versuchen, wieder detaillieren und wieder nochmal nachfragen.
Und Drogenkusen wurde verneint.
Der Patient treibt keinen Sport und Impfstatus sei unauffällig.
Der Patient sei vorstellig geübt gegen Corona-Empel, COVID-19.
Der Patient war letztes Jahr im Kenya.
Und wegen der Astrophlexie hat er eine Tablette eingenommen wegen Malaria.
Vor der Reise, genau.
Und der Patient sei verheiratet, hat keine Kinder,
wohnt mit ihrer Frau zusammen.
Genau, mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Und der Patient hatte einen Bruder, aber mit dem habe keine Kontakt momentan.
Bei der Familienvorgehichte fanden sie eine Brustkrebs bei der Mutter,
die vor fünf Jahren wegen Brustkrebs gestorben sei.
Und eine Apoplexie bei dem Vater, der letztes Jahr gestorben sei wegen Apoplexie.
Und eine Apoplexie gestorben sei.
Und der Patient arbeit aus Maurer in einer Baustelle.
Maurer, Maurer.
Maurer.
Ja, genau.
Maurer in einer Baustelle.
Auf der Arbeit sei der Patient zufrieden momentan.
Und die anamästischen Angaben deuten amästens auf eine Leberchirose hin.
Wegen dieser Leberchirose habe der Patient ein bisschen Anämie gehabt.
Und wegen dieser Anämie ist die Augen und die Haut gerettgeworden.
Nicht wegen Leberchirose.
Oder wegen dieser Leberchirose, genau.
Leberchirose.
Okay, sie gehen von einer Leberchirose aus.
Okay.
Ja, Alkohol.
Eine Leberchirose oder eine ethyltoxische Leberchirose.
Ethyltoxische Leberchirose.
Leberchirose.
Und alternativen kommen eine akute Cholestitis.
Und auch Hepatitis.
Ja, eine akute Hepatitis.
Ja, eine vollminale Hepatitis.
Und zur weiteren Abkühle werde ich die Patienten so als körperlich untersuchen.
Welche Diagnosen haben Sie noch?
Welche Diagnose?
Warum bekommt jemand Acetes?
Was ist Acetes wegen dieser Hepatitis?
Das haben Sie schon gesagt.
Eine andere Differenzialdiagnose.
Die Kolleginnen und Kollegen können helfen.
Woran muss man noch denken?
Wenn ein junger Mensch ein Acetes bekommt.
Alkohol hat man gesagt, Leberchirose haben wir gesagt.
Aber was kann noch Acetes machen?
Akute Pankratitis.
Das ist ein schwer verlaufen Pankratitis.
Rechtsherzinsuffizienz.
Da hat man keine Acetes.
Da hat man eine Rechtsherzbelastung.
Und auch eine Leberwenenstaurung.
Vielleicht im Endstadium.
Wo sind die Pektylogen?
Eine Tuberchirose.
Vielleicht.
Wenn ich richtig erinnere,
ich erinnere mich richtig.
Buchschere Sündung.
Das ist auch eine Lebergeschichte.
Welche Organe haben Sie?
Wenn es betroffen ist, macht Acetes.
Im Grunde, die Leberkrankung.
Das ist eine Lebergeschichte.
Was gibt es?
Wo sind die Onkologen?
Wo sind die Internisten?
Wir haben doch 20 Leute.
Du bist ein erfahrener Arzt.
Was zieht es?
Herz.
Nein, nichts.
Ja, von wem kommt das?
Peritoneum.
Wenn wir eine Peritonealmetastase haben,
eine Peterperitonealkarzinom haben,
das macht Acetes.
Wenn man ein Eierstockkrebs hat,
das metastasiert gerne ins Peritoneum.
Das kann ein Acetes bilden.
Oder eine andere Sorte von Krebs.
Wenn man eine Perytonium hat,
das kann ein Acetes bilden.
Oder eine andere Sorte von Krebs.
Das ist metastasiert ins Peritoneum.
Man kann das mit der Perytonium machen.
Das ist ein Männernis.
Das kann ein Acetes bilden.
Es gibt verschiedene erkannte Erkrankungen,
die das Peritoneum betreffen.
Man hat auch Acetes.
Das ist eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Man muss den Acetes punktieren.
Das analysieren.
Auf Bakteriologie,
auf Männernis, auf Männernis.
Man muss eine andere erkannte Erkrankung betreffen.
Eine Perytonialkarzinose.
Das ist die nächste Differenzialdiagnose.
Es kann sein,
dass ein Pankreaskarzinom entwickelt hat.
Mit Peritonealkarzinose.
Was auch Lebermetastasien gemacht hat.
Deswegen ist der Iterus nicht durch Alkohol,
sondern eher durch etwas andere.
Es gibt eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Das haben wir heute keine Intervon.
Sie haben hier keine Intervon.
Da ist es nicht zusammen.
Aber wir haben sie.
Der ist Doktorhautdassons.
Wie ist der Differenzialdiagnose?
Es ist gut.
Welche Differenzialdiagnose fehlt noch ein?
Wie Sie gesagt haben, metastasen und peritonemikarsinomen, akute Pankratitis und akute Kulestitis, wie
haben gesagt.
Aber das macht Schmerzen, ne?
Genau, das macht Schmerzen und der hat keine Schmerzen.
Eigentlich das war es.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ich habe heute vielleicht so ein bisschen weich sehr streng mit Ihnen, Dr.
Wagner, top damit.
Aber war gut, sehr gut.
Super.
Die Sprache ist gut, es riecht ein bisschen schnell, aber ist gut.
Was ist Ihre Prüfung?
Ich habe noch keine Prüfungtermin, aber ich glaube, in den nächsten Tagen werde ich diese
Termin kriegen und ich habe wie schnell möglich eine Termin angefordert, gewünscht.
Ich glaube, zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Sie haben gute Chancen, Sie machen das gut.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen anderen natürlich auch viel Erfolg.
Ich habe alles Gute.
Danke.
Okay, andere Kollegen noch Fragen.
Gelbfieber bei Kenia weiß ich nicht.
Früher hat man bei vielen Ländern Gelbfieberinfunk gemacht.
Hi, jetzt gibt es eine Liste, da kann man nachschauen.
Bei vielen Ländern braucht man es nicht mehr.
Bei Kenia, weiß ich nicht, bei Tanzania braucht man es glaube ich.
Bei Kenia nicht unbedingt, das ist glaube ich eher ein Malaria-Gebiet.
Das ist keine Eampfunktion, sondern mit malerien Tabletten.
Malaria-Tabletten.
Ein Problem, aber Türke, man tabelt durcheinander.